what was the for you like getting out
and like kind of glowing up right away
like how did you get on uh soul and otrs
I seen it I seen it I rad I I got out of
Pelican Bay and uh I hit up OTR right
away and cash new I was going to rap you
know King cash too and just I always
wanted to be from OTR just seen it OTR
was just it's OT R like just growing up
that was just OTR like for the hood
that's like that's OTR like they're just
like they blow up all their artists you
know what I'm saying they got a pretty
solid lineup I said I'm going to be from
there so I hit him up but I read in the
Gucci Man book and it's some real advice
you don't got to tell me your homeboy
hot you don't got to tell me that your
homie's popping and he knows how to rap
because if he was popping and he knew
how to rap I would have been heard about
him and right now I'm on everybody's
[__] Explorer and everybody's feed
and everybody's YouTube I'm on everybody
in all LA's stuff you cannot lie and say
you ain't see me you ain't see me you
asleep under a rock you probably missed
it I'm everywhere and I was ridiculous
I'm I don't even no this I'm passing by
I'm in a store on a sticker on a store
crazy story a sticker yeah on a
warehouse shoe sale my pictures on the
side for Street wise finish story what'
I say Gucci Man book I read the Gucci
Man book you read the Gucci book yeah
you don't got to tell me your homie's
hot your homie's popping your homie
knows how to rap your Beats are hot if
you're beat was hot I would have wanted
your beat if you if you were popping
soless would have been looking for me
you popping so I'm popping now you know
I'm some type of way and now OTR is
reaching out see me like hey like and
now they see the message back then it's
a funny story so I just manifested the
whole situation and now I'm OTR and yeah
I was doing it by myself I was getting
200,000 with a iPhone but n OTR just and
cool people say oh he got room whatever
nah it felt right it feels like family
he does everything for me Atlantic
anybody ain't going to do this for me
and hold my hand and just take me to the
top and put the actual love and support
and just believe in your music that's
what I want and soless believes in it
and that's why I'm I'm smoking the
competition in La I'm really money now
but he just he tells me in the car the
time like you want this you know and I
sit there like looking at him like what
the hell like this some movie [__] and I
was just like do I want it like you know
what I'm saying do I deserve do I want
it and yeah I want it but it's just like
my life's changing so quick and he's a
big part of it cash too like it's just
like it's happening so fast it's like a
perfect game it's like everything I ever
wanted it is it really is man once
you're hot and you're popping your
schedule's just locked in You're Just In
Motion I don't even know where the hell
we're going they just take me here and I
be like oh I remember this podcast from
when you know when I first started and I
was broke I remember looking at this one
this is it I'm here now cool I seen it
in my dream you know what I'm saying I
seen it in my vision type of stuff God
put it in my head cuz that's my vision
he didn't put it in my mom's head your
head your head your head you know how to
rap he got a gang of chains on huh
they're loud God damn he got a gang of
chains on let me B him fool you heard
that [__] you probably could have heard
it from right there that [__] sounded
like somebody moving a shopping cart and
it was a gang of gold chain it did sound
like that Jesus Christ that's a that's
just heavy huh oh man that's cool he
[__] on everybody end the
conversation